The SIS Wizard, the SIS Wizard app is. The
SISs Wizard app is powerful and dangerous. Uh
Sometimes you need to do something to your system. Normally
you might, you sometimes you need to do something with
your system. You need to install something or figure out
what's using all the disk space or something else that
you might normally go to the command line for. However
With AI and cognotic, you can have an LLM write
the shell script for you. You start with the, you
start at the goal tab of the system wizard and
type in what you want to do. Let's, for this
demonstration, do. That's. Right
Let's see your running processes. We saved the goal. We
are using Windows here. This also supports Shell, which is
um, Linux or Mac OS. It specifically uses Bash, but
we're going to be using Windows and PowerShell. We list
running processes in settings. We make sure that we have
a model selected. We have Gemini 3 Flash preview we're
going to use in this demo, and then we go
to the pipeline and generate a shell script. That
will be generated momentarily. And
here we go. We
can either use this directly in our own show or
we can click run and fix to test the script
Now, in this run and autofi session that appears. If
an error occurs, it will look into the error and
then try to code up a fix. If an error
were to happen, you would be able to run again
Well, you would be able to fix it. You would
be able to retry the execution in this interface. However
the first execution was successful and it is listing all
the processes that we can view here. The UI shows
that the command succeeded. Note that the UI does not
show the output of the command. You have to go
into the session link to view that detail. And there
you go. That is the system wizard. That is the
system wizard application. I hope you find it useful.